There seems to be a bit of a tradition
of making a special video when your
YouTube channel passes a million
subscribers.
'It is weighty...'
Now I was a
bit slow making mine
because - well - you're
about to see why. Essentially I wanted to
show how big a million is; a way to kind
of visualise it. This is where the idea
of printing pi to a million digits came
from. Of course a million digits of pi
have been known for a long time, you can
see them on the internet, even buy a book
of them; but I wanted to print it like a
conventional number, left to right on a
single piece of paper. I had no idea what
this would look like or even how big it
would need to be; so after a few emails
and phone calls - and this is cutting a
long story short - I ended up travelling
to Denmark to a printing company called
HSA Systems. These people were amazing
and it seems no job was too big for them.
Here I am with a guy called Torben who
was an absolute star and is the guy who
really made this happen from a technical
standpoint. For various reasons, including
the fact it's a monospace font, we
decided to print pi in Courier New. The
point size we chose was 8. This means
each digit was 40 pixels wide, one pixel
is one six hundredth of an inch, so each
digit was a fifteenth of an inch across.
Now this meant our million decimal
places, or a million and two if you count
the three and the decimal point, would be
1.05 miles long, nearly
1,700 metres - how is that for some
serious Numberphile action? Here we are
doing a test print run, and as you can
see it's on white paper.
Now Numberphile fans will know that we
love brown paper, and two reels of
special brown paper had been donated by
a UK company called Millingtons;
but it had not arrived. It was due to
arrive, it just hadn't. So it looked like
we might resort to using the white paper,
which was easier to get our hands on, it
was kind of like the backup. But, at the
last minute, like the last minute, the
brown paper arrived.
- 'You're our hero!'
There we go, here it is being mounted and
we're about to start printing. By the way
this guy is Hugh McPartlan, he's HSA's man
in the UK, he's with me here in Denmark,
and he's the real reason the whole
project really succeeded, you'll see more
of him later.
I have to say it was amazing how
smoothly the whole thing went and a
print run took about
48 and a half minutes.
It turns out the whole thing hinged on
this wheel, the encoder, which measures
how far along the paper we are. Now it's
just three one hundredths of a
millimeter off being a perfect circle
which means, I'm told, our spacing was
pretty good. And I must say I do find it
lovely how circles, and of course pi,
were used and were so instrumental in
our printing of pi. Now in addition to
just the numbers, the decimal places of
pi,
we included markers all the way along to
count the decimal places. There was a
marker every 10 digits. This was so we'd
be able to find parts of pi more easily
when the time came.
- Okay so I'm looking for
216182...'
- We also had a marker every
yard along the paper to give us an idea
of distance travelled.
Now I would have preferred metres, being
bit of a metric man myself, but for
complicated reasons it was hard to make
this synchronise. It all relates to the
fact the technology we were using to
print with is in dots per inch. It made
our chunks of pi more easily divided
into imperial units, we had a lot of
problems when we tried to do it in
metres. Now here's a quick interview with
Jesper, he's the boss at HSA, and another
man we owe a huge debt to.
- Well we do not
only do one type of printer, right? We do
a lot of different printers and printer
controllers that were manufactured from
HP
technology but also Xaar technology out of
England; Cambridge, England. We do both
software, we do the printed circuit
boards, we do the
printheads, the controllers,
everything right? We do a lot of
number printing. And that could be, for
example, lottery; it could be pin numbers;
it could be a unique identifier for
products. For example within the the food
industry, right, well they would- may
require a unique identification of a
certain product. And we would either
generate the number from- straight from
our software or we would load a database
and then print the numbers from the
database. Well numbers, mathematics, is
very much a big part of our day right?
Calculating DPIss and pulses per
rotation and what have we not so- and
I'll say we're not the ones doing the
hard mathematics, that's the the guys in
Copenhagen who who do the software and
also the core- the core of the software
doing the hard mathematics.
Namely calculating how to get a drop out
of the printhead at the right time, right
size, etc etc. So- but yes
mathematics is a very big part of our
our working day that's for sure.
- (Brady: Tell me)
what you know about pi?
What I know about pi? Okay. Well-
- (It's not a maths test!)
There's not a math test
(You obviously know the number?)
- Do I have to wear
flip-flops and a white sheet now or what?
(But like, you've never
print- have you ever)
(had to print out pi before?)
- No, never no,
We've never done that. We do- we do
make use of pi of course in our
everyday work, that's for sure, and we
know a bit about pi because we have to
do a bit of calculations when it comes
to
our tooling machines etc.
- (You've got circles everywhere!)
We've got circles everywhere,
yeah, and of course we
use pi a lot but we have never
done 1 million digits pi before on a
printing machine, so that's quite
exciting.
- (Have you done any number to)
(a million digits or am I your first?)
Well, you're the first where we've done a
million digits that's for sure.
(There you go Torben, you're
holding a big piece of pi there!)
So after printing our reel, what next?
Well, wrap it up of course, and then print
another one! We figured this would be a
handy backup if something went wrong. If
you're interested, the second roll was
never actually used and it's still in my
office. If you're some wealthy math
enthusiast you can even make me an offer
if you like - I'll warn you,
postage will not
be cheap. Now I also still have the HP
cartridges we used to print the whole
thing. Amazingly we used only 20% of a
cartridge, just over eight milliliters of
ink. This is what eight milliliters of
ink looks like, or 194 million tiny drops
from the printhead. The people at HP are
rightly proud of what their stuff can
do, it's called thermal inkjet technology.
They were also super excited when they
found out about the pi project and later
they helped me cover some of the
production costs. This was really
generous of them and I'm very grateful.
So, anyway, two rolls were printed and
then it was back to the UK for me and
the rolls were posted not far behind.
Here they are when they arrived at my
house. Next was arranging a way to unroll
the paper. Now after a wild goose chase,
and calling several Air Force bases, I
was able to hire the former RAF base at
Bruntingthorpe - that's
in Leicestershire in
England - which is now used as a car
testing track and aviation museum, they've
got all these Cold War jets there. I have
to say, if you like planes or exotic
sports cars, this is a place that will
blow your mind. Now a section of their
two-mile runway was sectioned off so we
could do our thing; it turns out no one
else was using the facility that day we
had the whole runway to ourselves. But we
were there with no real sense of how
difficult this might be, no idea how a
mile of paper could be effectively
unrolled. But that man Hugh, together with
a chap named Jon Kenny, devised an
ingenious contraption. Here are the
designs they made, and here is the real
thing after it was made by Jon.
Now I've got to admit I had a mild heart
attack here thinking the
paper wouldn't fit
Hmmm, not sure about that. But it got on
and we were able to start. Numberphile
regular and pi enthusiast Matt Parker
came along to be our tour guide; I should
probably thank him for giving up a whole
day but I think he enjoyed himself far
too much as it is.
- This is very exciting.
Now the unrolling was okay, and even
the rain was tolerable though a nuisance,
but the biggest problem was wind.
The wind was mercifully very light
this day but it still played havoc with
the paper. Luckily I'd brought some bags
of sand; we were able to use this to
weigh down the paper.
But the sand was
running out fast. We sent for more cones
which was stored elsewhere on the site,
they helped,
and then I went for a drive to the end
of the runway and found something else
that helped, these cone bases which were
nice and heavy but not too tall so we
could stack them in the back of the car.
Now while the runway crew worked really
hard on the rollout, Matt and I spent
some time further back recording pi
facts. Now much of this was cut from the
main video, that's just how things go, we
needed to keep the video short, but now
I'm going to show you more of them. Enjoy
these and when they're finished I'll
tell you more about how the day ended.
Pi - what a number. Abs-
it's unparalleled in mathematics. And, as
we all know, the digits never end; they
just keep on going forever and ever
which is incredible. And you can download
huge numbers of these digits and some
people, insanely, will print off tens
of thousands of them and make like a
poster. Not Brady, no. At Numberphile he
has printed off a million digits. So this
is the beginning and this is a mile; so
you can see they're unraveling it
further up there. there is one mile of a
continuous piece of paper-
Alright so it
is raining a little bit, but that's fine,
that's the great thing about pi, it
doesn't
change if it gets wet. So we're going to
begin our exploration and-
- (Wow, pi is the same when it's raining?)
I know, who knew! It's moisture invariant.
So here
I've marked the first 10 decimal places
that only use three different digits.
Okay here we've got 1565
51565666111;
and that is a run of 1,2,3,4,5,6,
7,8,9,10,11,12,13,14 - 15! -
which only uses three different digits,
so there you go. I mean-
so here at Numberphile
we're answering all the questions that
no one's ever asked.
Ok so we've come a fair way, where are we
now? We're up to a 121
yards, so we're at 11 squared yards, and
we're working away along. And I mean
famously people try and memorise pi. And
so I've got it down to, you know, the
first couple of digits
and - oh, one of our
support vehicles is coming up Brady, you
might want to pop out of the way, no it's
not. He stopped, he's getting out.
89,000-
If you take the alphabet; so A becomes 1,
B becomes 2, C becomes 3 and so on
you can turn words into letters. So my
name is Matt, MATT; M is the 13th letter
of the alphabet, A is the first, T is the
twentieth - so I'll be looking for
13012020 for 13 1 20 20; and you
can- oh we've gone
past it.
So that 02, that
is a - I'll put up here - that
is a B; work my way backwards. So before
that is a 12, that is a L, before that is
an 8 that's an H, before that is a 15
that's an O, before that is a 23
that's a W, before that is a 5
that's an E,
before that is an 8 that is
another H - ahh I'm
writing in a puddle!
Before that is a 14 that is a N,
before that is a 25 is a Y; and before
that is a 61 so ok so that's not-
so that there that is nine digits, well,
nine letters so it's 18 digits, and it
says YNHEWOHLB.
- (That's not a word!)
Well, it's a word. It's not a
word that makes sense, like it's not a
word in the English language but it is a
string of letters. And actually if you
want the longest word that makes sense
it's over here somewhere, we can go and
find that. Corot. That is the first five
letter word which is actually a
recognised word in the English language.
Corot was a French landscape and
portrait painter as well as a printmaker
in etching - there you go! Or Corot I
guess it should be. If we go all up to
we come across 'Grede';
not 'greed' as in 'greedy', grede: GREDE;
as in a leader in the development and
production of lightweight ultra
high-strength cast ductile iron
components. So it's a company called
Grede. After that's Bruel at 466574
digits. Bruel is a French
singer, actor, and professional poker
player. And then later on Kuthu which is
a 2004 Indian film; and then at the very
end, about nine digits before we finish,
is via fj - which I think looks a little
bit like via Fiji. Not impressive-
you look underwhelmed to be honest. A
lot of people think that any word, if you
look far enough, will be in pi somewhere.
And so far all the ones we've checked
are but it's not guaranteed. So pi, we
think, is something called a normal
number. However, we don't know for certain
if it is a normal number, we just think
it is. And if it is a normal number it
means any string of digits is equally
likely or appears with equal frequency
compared to any other string of digits
of the same length. And so
if it is normal
that's true, but we don't know. So
whenever someone says, any word or any
expression or any phrase you ever come
up with it somewhere
in pi, you can say ah,
we think so but we don't know for
certain. So the vast majority of real
numbers are normal but it's very hard if
you're given a number as an example to
prove that that number someone's given
you is definitely normal. In fact we've
done that so far for no numbers. No
naturally- like, no numbers we've just
found have since been proven to be
normal.
But we know that they're all out there, we
know most numbers are normal. In fact, the
complete works of William Shakespeare
appears in more numbers than it doesn't.
So I mean- so people say
that pi- it's not
that exciting when it comes to pi, in
fact my name Matt appears in the
first billion digits of root two, it's in
the first billion digits of e - I've
checked all these - and it's in the first
billion digits, I hate to say it, of the
golden ratio. So in fact if you pick a
number at random, odds are my name will
be in there probably in the first
billion digits. If you actually do want
to find your name in a
normal number, there
was a number called the
Copeland–Erdős number.
And what Copeland and
Erdős did was they got the number- they
started zero point and then it's all the
prime numbers in a row.
So it goes 2 and then 3 and then 5 and
then 7 then 1 and 1 for 11 and you just
put them in their base 10 form in there.
That number is proven to be normal
because it was generated to be normal.
And so if you have the Copeland–Erdős
constant in there somewhere, is
guaranteed to be the works of
Shakespeare, your name, what you're going
to have for lunch tomorrow; anyway you
want to encode it is in there somewhere.
I mean, it's also got the complete list
of everything you're not going to have
for lunch tomorrow, so it's not very
predictive. Pi will never fall into a
recurring pattern. So so no point will
it become recurring but you may have
incredibly long strings, maybe
infinitely long - not infinitely
long - you're looking at
very very long strings of digits or
predictable bits or- I mean 3.141592 it
may appear in there somewhere else. And so
any chunk I look at here that's going to
appear somewhere else but not in any
kind of predictable fashion. Pi is what's
called a transcendental number which
means you can't write it down in a nice
neat equation. So you can have equations
for pi, I mean somehow we calculated the
first million digits, but that's with an
equation where you always need more and
more terms to get more and more accuracy.
If you have a polynomial with
coefficients that behave themselves
you're never going to get pi out as an
answer, there's there's no repeating
finite way you can write down pi. Now
while we've been talking I've noticed
that the people putting down pi have
gotten substantially smaller; in fact
they're probably most of the way to the
horizon at this point so we should go- we
should go catch them up.
If I label that
you'll see here 176451
and the digits 314159,
there it is. 314159.
That is the longest bit of
the beginning of pi in pi in the first
million decimal places; so there it is.
314- I'm exhausted, I shouldn't
have run this far.
You know what's really
interesting right? People say pi is
random and this is a million
random digits so a lot of what we've been
finding are things you'd expect
anywhere in
randomness. But I've never seen this bit
of paper before in my life right? You
said 'Matt look up some things in pi'; I
just did it at home on my computer, but
yet when I come here to a million random
digits I knew exactly where that was
going to be. I came
along, there it is. Pi,
yes it's random, but predictable and we
can calculate it and it's always the
same and that's amazing,
I need a lie down.
There it is,
half a million. So that there is the half
a million digits of pi. If you don't
include the 3 at the beginning the
half million digit is a 2,
there it is, right
there. Far, far in the distance a
dedicated team of people with a trolley
with the pi like reel on it gradually
unrolling and, I mean, it's hard to tell
how much is left; if only we had some
kind of mathematical constant to
calculate how much paper is going around
it as it unravels - who knows? But they're
doing an amazing job and they're putting
it down faster than we're talking about
it which I find a little bit disturbing;
because they're all business. Like,
they've got a well oiled machine, cones
moving, things going down; whereas we're
just nerding out on 'hey look three 7s!'
and then they're disappearing off
into the dist- we probably
should either go and help
them or make them some tea.
You can see, I'll underline it there, it's
a bit small, that's 11492-
Okay, so before
that, if I- if we'd stop putting the pi
out here right, if that had been the end
of the piece of paper, every number from
1 up to 11491
is in there somewhere. So
is the biggest number for which every
smaller number is somewhere in there; and
then suddenly 11492
appears. And now you
think, well, you know,
where's 11493?
We've already had it. In
fact we've already had loads.
The next number, well- in the entire mile
of pi, as of now, the biggest number for
which every number smaller than is in
here somewhere is
14522. There is no
anywhere in the first
million digits of pi, it is the smallest
number which is not in the first million
decimal places.
- (Are you sure? You gonna check?)
I've checked! I- I think I've
got those digits right, I assure you if
I've gotten them wrong people will
leave a comment under the video. Okay,
so we've found 11492,
the next number up Brady is a
bit of a special treat for you, so we
need to go up into the- it's on the order
of 857,187
from memory - don't quote me on that,
let's find it. Okay we've actually got a
drone here filming which
is actually amazing
and as you can hear they're incredibly
subtle,
you wouldn't know you're being filmed by
a drone right now.
Modern technology man...
Five million, six hundred and thirteen
thousand, four hundred and eighty seven;
d'you recognise that?
- (I feel like I should)
You should, that is the
biggest Brady number
that appears in the first one million
decimal places of pi. So there you are,
that's- I honestly- that's seven
digits long.
I was I was astounded when I saw that
appear. So, I
mean, there's every four digit numbers in
here somewhere;
most of the five digit numbers;
reasonable chances on six - once you hit
seven it starts getting a lot less likely.
And so I thought, you know what, I'll just
check the Brady numbers. And sure enough
there it is. I mean we're not that far
from the end now, you can see our crew
just down there, I think they've almost
finished.
And so we're what- we're 85.7%
of the way through
the first million digits, sure enough,
a seven digit Brady num- I hate- I to
encourage the ongoing discussion and
research into Brady numbers but I'm very
impressed there's one just there.
- So, we'll film the
last little bit-
- It took three hours to
unroll the first half mile of paper, but
then the team got on a roll with the new
cones and the cone bases and a better
system and better weather; the next half
mile was all done within about an hour.
Now I did a bit of editing of
the video finale
when you watch the main film, but here's
how it played out without me interfering
with the editing.
Okay we're four hours into this and we
are nearly at a million digits. So
they've been coming out at a rate of a
quarter of a million digits an hour,
which is approximately 4167
digits a minute.
And we're- we're almost there. So, I mean
you guys have done the hard work, do you
want to wind off the last of this? And a
million digits is there! All right, so if
we- so if we just take that off there, all
right. So that is- there is wha- it's a
1, in case you're wondering. So we-
- Just tip it towards me a bit, yep.
- It's a
1. So there you go, we have just- I mean,
I think a token round of applause, well
done guys, we have just hit - that is the
quietest round of applause I've heard in
my life! Too tired to applaud. So, I
mean that is absolutely amazing; and
Brady, you have just set the world record
for the most digits of pi ever printed
out on paper. Although by simply adding a
three I will now have the world record
for the most digits of- 30 - is it a
nine or a seven? Two digits is good
enough. So I've now got the world record
for a million and two decimal places of
pi listed out. So that is absolutely
fantastic and now the very quick process
of rolling it all back up again before
an aeroplane lands.
- Cool, all right.
I should also thank James Hennessy and
Ed Fielden for doing much of the
camera work. I was very much focused on
the stuff with Matt but most of the
great shots you see in the final film
came from James and Ed. The drone shots, I
mean they were just amazing, I think I
could look at these all day.
Here I've marked the start and the end
point of our 1.05 miles.
Finally it was time to clear up-
- And I'm-
I'm not even 0.1% of
the way through!
- Before we started there'd
been plans to reroll the paper back onto
its reel but that was clearly misguided;
and besides the rain and wind had
wreaked havoc, finally weakening and then
starting to rip some sections of paper.
So I sent out two of my helpers, Josh and
Jacob, to salvage some of the best paper
snippets. I still have these ones as
souvenirs, it includes the start and the
finish of course. Some other people there
like Josh, Jacob, and even Matt I think,
also snipped out their birthdays where
they could find them within pi. The rest
of the paper was simply collected,
chopped up, screwed into giant balls and
sent to that recycling bin in the sky.
And with that the job was done. Now I
have to say, the whole task was probably
much harder than expected but also more
rewarding. And driving around on a runway
is awesome.
The whole thing wouldn't have been
possible without these people. I think if
the team was any smaller on the day we
may well have failed. Everyone really
chipped in and thank you to all of them.
And thank you to you for watching this
and watching all the videos here on
Numberphile. Hopefully you're among our
million subscribers and will continue to
be for years to come.
Okay you're gonna start seeing sand, that
is effectively ballast, paperweight.